لم تكن العلاقات بين روسيا والولايات
المتحده على ما يرام عندما انطلقت الحرب
في اوكرانيا فبراير الماضي لكن هذه الحرب
زادت العلاقات سوء حتى بدا في بعض الفترات
وكان البلدين وصل الى قطيعه شبه تامه الان
يجري دبلوماسيون روس وامريكيون اتصالات في
مدينه اسطنبول التركيه قال سيرجيريا نائب
وزير الخارجيه الروسي الى الاجتماع
اسطنبول خصص لمناقشه القضايا التي تثير
قلق الطرفين واضاف ان هناك املا في ان
تعود العلاقات بين موسكو واشنطن اذا
طبيعتها مع الوقت واكد ان روسيا لن
تقترحها ايضا على الولايات المتحده اجراء
مفاوضات بشان الضمانات الامنيه التي تخلت
عنها واشنطن بحجه الاحداث في اوكرانيا حسب
تعبيره يؤكد كلامه ان قنوات الاتصال قد
فتحت من جديد ويدمح الرئيس بوتن الى
استعداد للتفاوض على اساس الوقائعه على
الارض
العمليه العسكريه تسير بشكل طبيعي ولا
مشاكل تواجهها اما مسار التسويه بشكل عام
فنعم ربما لن يكون سهلا وسيحتاج وقتا
معيانا جميع المشاركين في هذه العمليه
سيتعين عليهم في نهايه المطاف القبول
بالوقائع على الارض
قال الرئيس الروسي ايضا ان عمليات تبادل
السجناء اخرين ممكنه مع الولايات المتحده
ما يعني ان هذه العمليات يمكن ان تبقي
قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه عمليه تبادل السجينه
الامريكيه بالسجين الروسي حركت المياه
الراكده في العلاقات الامريكيه الروسيه
تم الاتفاق عليها بين مخابرات البلدين
لكنه اوضح انه ليس لها اي تاثير على مجمل
علاقات البلدين التي قال انها تبدو سيئه
يبدو ان الملدين يا الغبان في ابقاء قنوات
الاتصال مفتوحه لكن لا يتوقع ان تعود
العلاقات الى طبيعتها ما دامت مستمره في
اوكرانيا وما دامت الولايات المتحده تدعم
اوكرانيا باسلحه متطوره وتفرد مع باقي
الدول الغربيه عقوبات على موسكو